[Musik]
dies ist die geschichte einer familie
zwischen der schweiz und dem
ecuadorianischen regenwald eine
geschichte über heimat zwischen den
welten remich und sein sohn jahren
fangen fische und den moment zu feiern
als alles anfing es war die zeit als
diese familie gegründet wurde und ihr
gemeinsames ziel der schutz des
regenwalds und seiner tiere seinen
anfang nahm
das ist 20 jahre her und heute werden
die vorbereitungen getroffen um mit
einem fest dieser arbeit im amazonas zu
gedenken
[Musik]
am anfang dieser geschichte stehen zwei
schweizerinnen die ihr herz an den
amazonas verloren haben
eine von ihnen ist die bernerin
christine von staiger 1991 reiste sie
zum ersten mal nach ecuador in den
regenwald am rio napo
[Musik]
der urwald das ist für mich immer das
traumziel sie nicht unbedingt die
südamerikanisch das ist ganz zufällig
sie sondern der verein afrikas asse
können sind wohin in assisi und wenn ich
dann daher ich bin sehr schmal
dann bin ich in den wald gestanden
der muss sagen da bin ich
zufälligerweise war die reiseleiterin
von christine auch eine schweizerin und
auch sie war von der natur im amazonas
tief beeindruckt und so beschlossen sie
zusammen eine tierstation zu gründen
ich traf angelika reimann eine eth
agraringenieurin einige jahre später am
selben ort
die schweizerin hatte sich in remich jo
verliebt einem indio vom stamm der cage
war einen fremden mann zu heiraten und
mit ihm zwei kinder zu zeugen war ein
großer schritt
aber jetzt muss sie zur firma händler
lang probiert beides merkt aber es
hätten mehr kaputt das heißt ich bin
sehr stolz auf sie dann binnen drei
wochen kurzem mit ihrer züge und hat
immer noch besser klappen nicht schweiz
kommen und denken merken was eigentlich
dass das wasser zu schütten sind aber
sind zu verschieden
denn angelika und lucio hatten ein
gemeinsames ziel das engagement für die
natur verletzte und gefangen gehaltene
tiere wurden gepflegt und wieder
ausgewildert über jahre entstand der
amazon ico eine arche noah des
regenwalds sicher vor constrictor
schlange die hsk plastikflaschen hat
spielzüge und einfachheit bei dem als
die fläche geschüttet und machen und hat
sich hier einfach noch einmal geweckt
weil sie halt praxis und den helm er sie
überhaupt sie statt x 80 cm groß sie
wenn sie luft pro für parasiten
loswerden und jetzt gehts eigentlich
sehr gut zwischen weiter 60 jahren noch
wenn sie nicht weiter wenn sie nicht gut
ich merke nicht richtig sie dort einfach
sich gründet die sache dann wegen
subjektiv aus
angelikas kinder waren dschungel kinder
kinder der indios mit einer mutter aus
der schweiz ihre heimat war der
regenwald der weg in die zukunft
zwischen den welten damit sie beide
später selber konnte was sie werden wenn
das sie spagat machen respektive
zwischen zwei welten
das war vor 14 jahren
ich möchte wissen wie die geschichte
weiter gegangen ist
es ist sommer 2013 im zürcher unterland
angelikas kinderjahren und sylvia leben
inzwischen bei der großmutter nach der
primarschule in ecuador gehen sie jetzt
in der schweiz ins gymnasium
dieser schritt hatte sich langsam
abgezeichnet doch dann schlägt das
schicksal zu kalt und unbarmherzig die
mutter stirbt 2011 in ecuador bei einem
autounfall
also es hat mir schon recht auf den
boden geworfen aber es muss wieder und
sind hinter und ich weiß dass ich
aufpassen muss dass ich zum kleben
wo wollen sie hin zustande bis die ihre
ausbildung fertig endmontage und das
golden boy und dafür muss ich da sie die
großmutter die ursprünglich aus
deutschland in die schweiz kam hat sich
noch einmal die bilder aus ecuador an
angelika war ihre einzige tochter die
großmutter sagt die kinder verdrängten
den tod ihrer mutter
sie redeten nie davon sie müssen selber
entscheiden ob sie in die schweiz kommen
wollten
der jahn hat mir eines tages anbietet
und hätte mich kredite durch daher und
jetzt ganz hält der zug sei thoma hälfte
auch sehen wir hätten lieber ist ganz
ganz fest verbunden mit dem regenwald
es ist wird sie für sie vom vater weg zu
gott und das wisse dass er dann ganz
allein ist weil er hätte jetzt frau und
kind verloren
und da sehr darunter
ein bis zweimal pro jahr reisen jahren
und sylvia nach ecuador und besucher in
ihren vater jetzt in den sommerferien
ist es wieder soweit
es ist lange her seit sie ihn gesehen
haben
es ist werden wir nach fast einem jahr
wieder dort das ein unbeschreibliches
gefühl wenn man ins boot steigt und dann
wieder massa nico fährt und die bäume
sieht und die menschen die dort sind und
eigentlich hat sich nicht viel verändert
nur kleine sachen aber an sich ist es
immer noch das gleiche immer wieder ein
wunderschönes gefühl eigentlich endlich
ist es soweit
der vater hat seine kinder mit dem boot
ab
[Musik]
es liegt eine seltsame kälte über diesem
wiedersehen
später erklärt mir der vater dass sich
die ketscher nicht gewohnt sind gefühle
zu zeigen
es gebe in ihrer sprache auch kaum worte
dafür
damals so nico liegt direkt am fluss zur
station gehören 18 quadratkilometer
geschützter regenwald und eine lodge mit
bungalows mit dem öko tourismus
finanziert die familie einen teil der
station
wie geht es für mich nur zwei jahre nach
dem tod seiner frau
der tod von mama hinterlässt eine
riesige leere und die kinder die wegen
der schule in der schweiz sind fehlen
hier sehr wenn sie in den ferien bei mir
sind bin ich sehr glücklich und ich
hoffe fest dass ich mich auch vermisst
haben
sie werden remigius kinder nach der
schule in der schweiz zurück zum vater
kommen was wäre das für ein leben
um mehr darüber zu erfahren treffen wäre
mich aus eltern die indianischen
großeltern von jahren und sylvia nebst
rio haben sie 16 weitere kinder und
neben jahren und sylvia eine kaum mehr
zu überblickende zahl von enkeln also
meine mutter führt da nicht buch ich
habe keine ahnung
vor ein paar jahren macht mir eine
kleine zählung da waren es etwas über 80
die ganze familie mit allen brüdern und
schwestern
aber heute sind es natürlich noch viel
mehr zum beispiel der kleine dort unter
ihnen allen war angelika die einzige
weiße
[Musik]
eigentlich wollten meine eltern ja dass
ich eine frau von hier heiraten
aber ich arbeite als führer und als ich
angelika kennenlernte sagte ich ihnen
das ist meine entscheidung
[Musik]
wie sagten okay solange sie in der nähe
lebt und zu dir passt und angelika
passte gut für die familie ist es klar
dass jahn und sylvia einmal das erbe
ihrer mutter antreten werden
in diesen sommerferien besucht auch
christine von steigert den amazon com
sie hatte nicht nur die idee dazu
sie finanzierte auch die ersten jahre
von ihren ersparnissen aber während
remich und angelika im regenwald blieben
kehrte christine zurück in die schweiz
jetzt ist sie hier um das 20 jährige
jubiläum des projekts mit zu feiern
[Musik]
was vor 20 jahren eine kleine arche noah
zweier schweizerinnen war ist heute ein
schiff mit einer großen mannschaft
dutzende von catcher familien haben
immer mazzoni keine arbeit gefunden wo
sie früher von einfacher landwirtschaft
lebten haben sie heute einen
zusatzverdienst dass köche torhüter oder
handwerker auch christines beitrag wird
gefeiert
als immer mehr lokale familien mit
kindern sich am projekt beteiligten ließ
sie für sie eine schule bauen und die
lehrer aus pool und terrasse schweiz
hier bekamen jahren und sylvia die
ausbildung mit der sie den anschluss an
das schweizer gymnasium schaffen konnten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für christine liegt es nahe dass jan
eines tages das projekt übernimmt
aber einfach wird es nicht die
primarschule des amazon ico
während sie wer den schritt ins
gymnasium machte wurden ihre kolleginnen
mütter silas freundin ist 16
von ihrer mutter lernte silvia zuerst
die ausbildung dann eine familie oder
noch besser zuerst eine ausbildung nach
schweizer maßstab guten schüler
schreiben ein bisschen setzt auf so hier
ist es abschreiben und auswendig lernen
und bei uns ist es also jetzt in der
schweiz ist es dann irgendwie denkt
darüber nach lernen es richtig besteht
dass auch unser bist du bist also ich
find das abschreiben leicht aber ich
lerne besser wenn ich darüber nachdenke
[Musik]
einige wochen vorher im internet
immensee im kanton schwyz erst seit
einem halben jahr geht sie wer hier zur
schule in der mathematik stunde verteilt
der lehrer die ergebnisse der letzten
prüfung
das große problem ist ja dass sie viel
glück gebracht hat
der vorgänger schule wo sie für heute
und jetzt natürlich so dass
schwierigkeit im unterricht kann jetzt
folgen und einer live ticker bringen und
dank das ist das frustrationspotenzial
für sie
ich glaube sich viel im nachbarschaft
von probiert und es blieben aber und den
offenen schlacht die noten über und dann
gibt's ja es schwierig für sie
silvia sagt sie sei ehrgeizig und wolle
diese ausbildung unbedingt abschließen
statt in einer hütte lebt sie jetzt
unter der woche in einem zimmer des
internats zusammen mit einer freundin
uns der üblichen ausrüstung digitaler
teenager es war kein einfacher wechsel
in eine neue welt
sie machen nicht viel sie gehen einfach
in die schule und haben dann ihre hobbys
eine zu hause mussten wir auch andere
sachen mache also werten weniger
freizeit und sie arbeiten zwar länger in
der schule und haben auch eine schwerere
schule aber abseits von den können sie
einfach machen was sie wollen
nach der matur werde sie zurück in den
regenwald gehen sagt silvia zwei jahre
sind seit dem tod von angelika m amazon
ico vergangen
remich und sein sohn jahren bei einer
bank wo ein
[Musik]
ich begrüße euch alle hier vor allem auf
jahren und sylvia die in den ferien aus
der schweiz hergekommen sind
ich freue mich sehr mit euch allen
unseren neuen banknoten zu wahren
[Applaus]
noch immer liegt ein schleier trauer
über allem das neue haus wird auf den
namen jan getauscht
vater und sohn möchten damit den
aufbruch in eine neue zeit signalisieren
[Applaus]
viele teile dieses projekts geleitet das
heißt sie mussten diese teile übernehmen
und durch andere person ersetzen was
eigentlich sehr schwer möglich war
und das hat uns zurückgeworfen aber
jetzt haben wir langsam den dreh raus
und schaffen das zu ersetzen und dadurch
sind wir jetzt wieder guten weg das war
früher nicht so ich diesen verlust
und so geht die aufgabe weiter das
engagement für den regenwald und seine
tiere manchmal fahren jahren und sein
vater zu einer insel unweit des amazon
ico hier leben offen die sie in der
station aufgezogen haben
jana und revision wird dann die waffen
mit hühnereiern einer delikatesse für
sie
[Musik]
beim schutz der affen apricot viel
erreicht
wir haben viel arbeit investiert in den
schutz des waldes und der tiere
es ist wunderschön hier und ich habe
mich daran gewöhnt dafür zu leben
[Musik]
heute sagt man es ist ein weltweites
problem dass wir die umwelt zerstören
und deshalb ist dieser kampf meine
wichtigste aufgabe
ich hoffe auch für dich jan spürt die
erwartungen seines vaters
ich bin noch zum keine möglich im
schluss gekommen aber dass das ziel
dahinter das eigentlich dass ich
irgendwas zurückkomme und das ganze
übernehmen und mich um die tiere hier
kümmern zum wald
und aber noch meine ausbildung beenden
bald macht jahren die matur
doch wer weiß schon ob es so kommt wie
erwartet
denn eines lehrt diese geschichte pläne
sind das eine das schicksal ist etwas
anderes
ich habe hier der blick kaum auf so hieß
es auch wenn christine selber hat auch
pläne für die zukunft
eines tages möchte sie selber für immer
hierherkommen
[Musik]